Hey guys, welcome back to the channel I hope
you're all doing well. In today's video,
I will show you all different colossal titans in
attack on titan. First colossal titan we see in
the show is Berthold he had one of the strongest
titan powers but he was weak-minded and he lacked
determination, he was always listening to Reiner
and Zeke and he always obeyed their orders. He was
defeated in Shiganshina at the end of the season
3 and his colossal titan power was transferred to
Armin. He appears again briefly, near the end
of the manga when Eren summons all past titan
shifters. In this form we can only see half of
his body that is connected to Eren's founding
titan with a bunch of bones. Next, we have wall
titans, these titans are about 50 meters tall and
they can be found in every wall on the paradise.
They were made by king Karl Fritz with the power
of the founding titan, their purpose is to protect
the last Eldian territory on the island. These
titans were later freed by Eren Yeager who used
them to eradicate all life outside of paradise.
After Armin inherited colossal titan power from
Bertholdt we could immediately see that he would
be stronger than him. In terms of pure destruction
power, the two are very similar but when it comes
to the tactics and strategies Armin is definitely
stronger than him. Armin has everything Bertholdt
lacked, he is brave, determined, and he has
something to fight for. Even though we don't see
many colossal titans throughout the series we can
certainly say that Armin is one of the strongest
that ever had his power. By the end of the manga,
we are introduced to another colossal titan
Eren Yeager. After the alliance defeated his new
titan form he used the power of the founding titan
to transform himself into a colossal titan. After
that, he tried to fight Armin in his titan form
it looked like he was winning but their fight was
stopped by Mikasa. Based on these events we can
say that Eren is definitely the strongest
colossal titans we ever saw in the show,
and maybe even the strongest that ever existed.
Thank you guys so much for watching i really
hope you liked it you can subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss any future videos.